(soft piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal. Naked. Large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet, filled with optimism,
we grow up slowly. We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible by the
generosity of humans like you.
(upbeat music)
Thank you very much.
What I want to talk
about is dealing with the
organization of human society
and the nature of human society.
And I believe that if we think of it
in general evolutionary terms,
we see that the organization
of human society
is really quite different to that
of our nearest primate
cousins, the chimpanzees.
I think that manifest the
results of the difference
are clear and they're two.
One of them is that we are
able to build up societies
at far greater size than we find
in the other close primates,
and greater complexity.
And the second one
is that we think of
our social organization
as lasting far, far longer
than the life of the people
who might be part of that society.
I believe that both these differences
are due to the fact that
many aspects of human
society are imaginary.
And therefore I'm going to
start to look at imagination
in the certain art of detail.
The notion of imagination
isn't very often linked
with creativity and quite rightly.
And it is also linked
with individual creation.
That's not what I'll be talking about.
I'll be talking about
something quite different.
Which is shared imagination.
How the same imaginary features
are shared within a group.
And how that comes back is
due to a number of factors,
but I think already if we
remember the slide we've seen
about pretend pay, we can
see that both there seems
to be a general predispositions
in humans for pretend play.
But that pretend play gets
slot-in with things which are
instituted within the
culture and the society
of people who are doing this pretend play.
So I think we have to
think of predispositions
enabling us to take on
historically created structures.
Like schools was obvious
in the last picture
in that series about pretend playing.
We have to think of this
articulation between
the two kinds of things.
How, as I was saying,
how is articulates...
So, what I'll be talking
about is not individual
imagination, though
obviously it's involved,
but the sharing of imagination.
And let me go back to
what I started off with,
saying that there are many aspects
of human social organization
which have to be imaginary.
First factor of this I want to talk about
is the notions of the groups
we often think we belong to.
Let me start off with
the examples of clans,
which we find in various
forms in many human societies.
Now, one of the interesting
things about humans,
about clans, is that they're
thought of as lost in time
far longer than the
life-span of individuals.
That already means that
they have to be imaginary
because obviously if they were
attached to the individuals
they would sort of end or
have no great continuity.
But this would also be true of nations.
For example, one can think
of the Greeks as a nation,
quite apart from their
territory, having gone on
for very, very long periods
in time the Greeks continued,
they passed on from one
another something called...
a vague Greekishness that
is very difficult to define
what that might be and
very interesting, it is
difficult even for the
people who think this is
extremely important to define it.
So, again we imagine, and
I think I can use the word,
that there is a level,
a twitch, a social continues
on quite a different time-scale
than the life, our biological life.
That doesn't mean...
And there is another factor
which is even more important.
We continually think of as an
important part of our society
is that we have instituted roles.
Husband, a wife, to use an example which
was used by the philosopher Searle.
But policemen, and so on.
Now, there is something
rather odd about these roles.
Because they can't, they
don't seem to have very little
to do with what people actually get up to.
People may hate each other,
husbands and wives may
hate each other, but we think
there is something about
being husband and wife
independently of this.
So, if we think of our
society as systems of roles,
as a large number of roles,
we realize we have to
think on another level,
on an imaginary level.
Other than the
interactions, which has been
the greatest focus in
psychology when people
are thinking of the social.
We have to think of how it is
possible that these systems,
that they're shared systems of the social,
which don't correspond
to anything empirical.
I should've mentioned that
when I was talking about clans,
that clans, you know, if
people can imagine themselves
as belonging to clans
without anything obvious
marking them out from people
who belong to other clans,
that they usually do not live together,
that they're dispersed,
it's somehow there is
a level, an imaginary
level that which people
can think of themselves as one.
So, this is really presents...
This is something which we do not find
in any other primates.
This is why I would argue
that we should stop thinking
of human society as a sort
of incremental business
of getting better and better
at knowing other people
and knowing the world.
There is also a discontinuity
which I would identify
with the presence of that imagination.
Having said that, however,
this presents a problem.
How, with what I started
off with talking about,
which is I was saying
something very different about
human societies is that
they seem to be able
to be expanded to
extraordinarily large size
in a way that doesn't
apply to other primates.
And that there's also this idea
of them continuing in time.
Of course, this is not
a problem if by society
we mean these imaginary representations
that I was talking about.
They can be as large as you like.
Or as and, indeed,
their systems, which are
not tied to particular moments.
But I was talking about practical results.
How can this imaginary level
have practical results?
Which are tremendously
important if we want
to understand the
evolution of human society.
I think we answer comes from the fact that
this imaginary level is not as imaginary
as it might seem at first.
There are what I've called emergences.
That is moments when
the shared imagination
is actually acted out,
where people can live in
the shared imagination
as well as they live in the
practical, interactional world
which is normal, sort
of every day leveled.
These are very largely
rituals which involve
people losing many of
the aspects of themselves
as individuals in that what characterizes
rituals is their
repetitions of previous...
People say the same things
other people have said.
They, therefore, lose
their intentionality.
They become kind of elements
in an abstract structure,
but it is acted out.
And at other moments...
In normal life, or in
normal traditional life,
people step in and out
of the imaginary level
to an interactional level,
and they're able to hold
two quite different ways
of thinking about society.
This is what is not
found in other primates.
And this has practical results.
For example, if you
imagine yourself living
in a pre-Neolithic village
and you want to set up
another... to move to another village,
you have to move to this imaginary level
in order to be able to build
up kinship relationships
with other people, people
in that other village.
Convince them somehow
that there is something
in common and that is
moving to another level,
to that imaginary level.
And then you can move
to that sort of place.
This, I think, explains
how pre-ape humans managed
to have very far-reaching
and distant trading relationships.
And, also, to the other practical level,
to the other practical
factor, which is imagining
that your society lost in time,
that somehow we imagine
that we have a social
which lasts in time quite independently
of our biological life.
It means that there is some point in...
First of all, in passing
on, and accumulating
either objects because
we are passing them on
to people that we don't know
with who are our continuation
but only in imagination.
And, perhaps, passing
on knowledge which then
becomes the basis of what
the evolutionary biologist
Michael Thomas Seller has
called the wretched effect
that is building up
on knowledge which is already there
so that it can be then
be used for evermore complex systems.
This is the basically the
ability in human culture
to continue and to
accumulate and to advance.
So the possibility of
stepping in to moments of
what is normally shared imagination
explains, I think, the most
fundamental differences
between our society and the society of,
as I said, the chimpanzees.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(peaceful music)